welcome to this video against Dark
Passenger did I did I check who that is
yep and there's still no name okay what
do we get Queens gambit triangle yeah I
Quincy to with my long term move against
this good that's a good compromise
between ambition and simplicity it still
has it still can play wow really this is
still a move which you can use to play
for an advantage but it is five never
seen that one interesting now I'm but it
is still I'm not very young a very
complicated move to learn from a bit I'm
a bit surprised by this development I've
never seen that that kind of that kind
of play in this in this line with see
596 interesting so why am I going to do
that just normal and let's play very
classically we should g5 III and stuff
not sure g3 certainly also was possible
they're ok I have played creasy to c4 as
well so seasick 765 is some somewhat
slowish but it's not it's not like I'm
having a huge development edge aiming
for Bishop f6 hmm
so he allows me to take on f6 oh ok or
Bishop f4 by the way it's also not a bad
move but let's let's make sure that the
structures compromised if I go night
efore here intending luke t 7 let's
Bishop e7 and it's still now then I can
play Knight f6 hmm not sure how good
that is and I'm sure
this should be 79 f 6 Bishop f6 queen
before hmm I'm not sure this is a clean
pawn or am I I mean I'm neglecting
development quite clearly now that it's
check it still should be good right I
have Queen g4 check which is an
important important feature of this
position check King edge aight check for
Bishop d3 route g8 Queen h5 there what
is queen e for better actually now then
we should be towards each okay it's not
a good idea let's do it like that okay
he just takes it hmm yeah so I can take
either cases see it's got this check
here I wonder maybe I should just castle
first it's also Queen sees reach c3
check and to g7 ok I'm going to castle
first
so my tachyon ig5 Queen h5 is certainly
interesting rook GA it was actually the
move I did expect but didn't happen
Queen edge 5 f-5 not g5 I thought would
be rather good let's do it attacking on
e6 yeah can you play route yet maybe you
can never know this one
pawn takes Knight takes is six I guess
or Fe for Bishop Bishop before is
actually also quite a good move not sure
what's better actually takes Knight
takes a very very messy stuff he might
also if he gives away they exchange get
the pawn or d3 which I cannot easily
capture
hmm remarkable that this stuff might
work so if I've it's really really
remarkable
okay if I take is six Quincy fighters
still made on age seven I don't know I
cannot calculate this stuff here
impossible at least for me it's
impossible maybe Bishop g2 is a move
here I don't know but then night f7
maybe yeah another seven that's not
going to work Bishop g2 what do i do
then night f7 he can play rock g server
look at seven
okay again I cannot take and now g5 is
Han why it's not completely hanging
maybe just this move I mean something to
h6 I take 49 f 7 and now I'm threatening
night f7 for winning the Queen check the
low humming reasons oh wow this was
tough so let's let's let's have a look
from here went here would be 1 so this
now okay I went here and maybe okay the
computer wants to play Queen to c4 and
then to g4 interesting yeah this is this
sauce was a bit disposal risky is maybe
wrong wrong word but this is not a
completely clear situation it took okay
this okay the computer wants to do this
ok it's not afraid of any check on c3
then f 5 9 g5 Bishop c6 northern 96 wins
computer ik Bishop c8 with the slight
edge for white ok very very difficult to
understand it looks like black is in
trouble but it's it's difficult
this is this here no I Wendy for
compounds to take on e4 now this takes
sticks and now we r f e6 and white is
better indeed okay kicks I was I wasn't
totally sure what to do after that move
computer gives h4 with an edge for wide
yeah I actually thought about the move
but I wasn't I wasn't sure it's
obviously rather yea rather difficult
his position but here black has some
issues of course what is he doing
threatening night p.m. and also Bishop
h7 it's not so easy to defend this if
possible at all 1.74 white has the comp
evaluation g3 is right rupee 5 & 9 9 f 7
as in it's over yeah that looked a bit
recently played by me the computer
doesn't find a very obvious improvement
very complicated very complicated game
yeah I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching